bonsoir et merci d'être en direct par
téléphone avec nous sur rt france
manifestations pro-palestiniennes
interdite à paris quand elle a été
autorisée dans d'autres villes en france
est ce que vous comprenez ce traitement
différencié côté manifestement que
l'exécutif a voulu certainement déployer
une réponse qui se voulait équilibré
c'est à dire éviter le maximum de
risques là où on considérer que la
concentration des vip qui était maximale
c'est-à-dire à paris notamment d'acteurs
de barbès et laisser la possibilité aux
gens on va constater simienne manifesté
en province
quoiqu'il y ait eu quelques
manifestations qui a été également
interdite en province froide n'y fait et
à grenoble
ce que vous voyez la gestion de la
mobilisation parisienne aujourd'hui par
le gouvernant par le gouvernement et par
les forces de l'ordre
écoutez ce qui est la préoccupation
réformant première du gouvernement
encore cette affaire et éviter
d'apporter le conflit israélo
palestinien en france où l'on sait qu'il
existe un certain nombre de tensions
communautaires et on peut imaginer que
dans finalement la la la la volonté des
ministres à l'intérieur d'interdire
cette manifestation via la préfecture de
police
il y avait vraiment cette plantation
ensuite la gestion sur le terrain
suggestion que l'on rencontre maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois à voir maintenant
depuis plusieurs années lors de ce type
de rassemblement avec d'inévitables
échauffourée avec une police qui est
aujourd'hui aussi mieux extrêmement de
mobiliser extrêmement fatiguée parce que
il faut bien comprendre que quand le
mamba d'emmanuel macron nous avons connu
des crises successives les forces de
l'ordre ont été très souvent ils ont
mobilisé donc il ya aussi cette volonté
vraisemblable de 2,2 de permettre au
four de long dont 6,2 de souffler un peu
même si c'est manifestement pas que
quelqu'un plus tard je souhaite après
médias paule et aux vieux justement
cette mobilisation cet après midi qui
s'est tendu et malgré son interdiction
vous dirait
le conflit au proche orient est en train
de s'exporter en france en tout cas nous
avons des gérants france de 7,7
importations or si ce constat ne date
pas du mandat
ça manque emmanuel macron donc il est
clair que pour tout gouvernement lorsque
la situation se tend dans cette région
du monde il ya tenant la volonté de
permettre que on évite des débordements
qui sont des débordements communautaire
on se souvient que les magnification de
2014 notamment avait donné lieu à des
échauffourées il ya des slogans
notamment antisémites
donc il ya en tout cas les risques qui
existent dans la société française qui
fête sa composition sociologique et bien
évidemment il est tout à fait légitime
elle que l'exécutif est aujourd'hui
s'assure que ce conflit ne déborde pas
ici on a entendu un certains
manifestants portaient à la position de
la france qu'elle est la posture des
manuels maquereau en face au cv aux
événements qui se déroulent entre
israéliens et palestiniens
écoutez la posture emmanuel macron c'est
une posture qui est j'allais dire de
contente dans la position diplomatique
française sur ce conflit c'est à dire
bien évidemment nécessité de trouver une
solution politique n'est évidemment que
les intérêts de l'état et des
populations et leur veine également la
nécessité de permettre la naissance d'un
état palestinien
aujourd'hui on réduit en être l'autorité
une autorité sur le terrain des
compétences y compris puisque on voit
bien que c'est aujourd'hui de la marque
ses courses dans parfois extrêmement
radical il faut bien dire que l'on
risque de mener une lutte pour la
reconnaître
merci beaucoup arnaud un benedetti je
rappelle que rédacteur en chef de la
revue la politique et parlementaire